hey guys my name is Jeff it is the 13th
of December and it is the temperature of
the Sun in Sydney so just in case it is
indeed the apocalypse I'm gonna make
sure you get your gaming news first
let's do it first up here's all the
expansions updates and events you can
enjoy from a few of your favorite games
starting today GTA online's
import/export expansion has now arrived
so gear up to steal cars and become even
more of a badass criminal than what you
already were in the future adventures in
finance and felony update you'll also
get a garage to store your 60 stolen
cars and the more you Nick the closer
you'll get to unlocking special missions
a new adversary mode called turf wars
has also arrived where you compete to
control tiles from your vehicle not a
fan of the grand theft daughter no
worries over watches Christmas update is
now live oh you can dig into winter
themes Luke boxes that grab new skins
and try out an event specific ball mode
called may snowball offensive where six
players of May or compete to take each
other out with one shot snowball guns
Destiny's holiday event of the dawning
is also out today for people who own the
rise of iron expansion and carrying
through that winter theme for to horizon
threes Blizzard mountain expansion is
Nell out it may not be winter themed but
battlefield ones latest patch adds the
game's first free DLC map giant shadow
as well as the grenade crossbow yes that
is a thing you need premium members get
the new map today while everyone else
will have to wait until december twenty
the update is also made balance changes
for weapons and items and introduced a
spectator mode for more details on any
or all of these updates check back to
GameSpot's ukulele the spiritual
successor to banjo kazooie now have a
real estate developer platonic games
announced the game will launch on April
11 2017 and that's the good news the bad
news is that the game is no longer
coming to wii u not to worry because i
have good news again along with ps4 xbox
one pc mac and linux ukulele seems like
it might also be coming to nintendo
switch the dev explained despite our
best efforts and exploring every
possible Avenue we've encountered
unforeseen technical issues that
unfortunately mean it will
impossible for us to release the game on
where you as initially planned we're now
working very closely with Nintendo to
look to bring ukulele to the upcoming
Nintendo switch finally upcoming hack
and slash game for honor will require
and always online internet connection
Ubisoft's community rap you beat
Jurassic confirmed the news in a forum
post saying we can confirm that for
honor is an always-online experience
some elements of progression which is
hosted online are shared across story
and multiplayer modes players will need
to be connected to the Internet at all
times to play for honor Ubisoft has
since confirmed to gamespot that the
game will indeed require an internet
connection sauna will arrive on ps4 xbox
one and pc on febri 14 of 2017 so happy
Valentine's Day go forth and cut down
your enemies with a broadsword or
whatever that is everything I've got for
you today do you remember the next
tuesday december twenty we're counting
down our top five games of the year live
on gamespot so pop by for that and I'll
for you again tomorrow